alrighty um another day another video um
first of all i'd like to welcome the
actual people who subscribe to the
channel because i guess they're actually
going to be a few of you now but um
it's like a little bit concerning for me
since i've kind of been saying some
[__] up [__] on here but uh
i'm not stopping so i'm gonna keep going
um second of all is for those of you who
just arrived um i'm probably only gonna
be making systems design content for now
um which is good because i just feel
like anyone who does like the day in the
life of a google software engineer is
just like a massive tool and like only
shows themselves getting like six
macchiatos during the day and like never
actually shows the fact that they've
been ripping their hair out over a
software bug for like the last three
days and not making progress on their
sprint
so uh yeah those are disingenuous um
i'll probably still make one though once
i you know want more views but anyways
um
today we're going to be covering
partitioning or database sharding
whichever one you want to call it which
is also pretty equally important then
after that i'll probably go into
transactions and you know the challenges
that arise with those and then finally
i'll actually do a database comparison
so if you're waiting for that it'll
happen soon but uh yeah without further
ado let's get into sharding
okay so let's talk about partitioning
also known as data sharding
what is partitioning well when you're a
huge company and you have a ton of data
inevitably what's going to happen is
that your database tables are going to
get too big so much so that they aren't
even able to fit on a single system
anymore partitioning is taking a
database table and breaking it up into
chunks so that each chunk can be placed
on different nodes
partitioning is also often used in
conjunction with replication which means
that for example each partition might
have a bunch of replicas of that
partition
okay what are the objectives of
partitioning well there are pretty much
two
each partition we want in theory to have
a similar amount of data which means the
same amount of keys on it and values
more or less and additionally a similar
amount of queries which means that we
don't want it to be the case that um one
partition has an absolute ton of queries
on it so for example you know like
if you're instagram the amount of users
might be the same on each partition but
one of them might be verified and as a
result of that there's a ton of data to
store there and a ton of queries on
their account that have to be read
if we can't achieve this and one
partition either has a ton of data or a
ton of load on it that's known as a
hotspot
okay so there are two methodologies that
we'll talk about for partitioning your
data
and the first one is by ranges of keys
and the second one is by ranges of the
hash of keys so keep in mind that i said
the range of the hash of the keys here
you don't just take the hash of the key
and then modulo the number of servers
you have that are serving partitions
because that would mean that if you
added another server
that you would use to store partitions
everything on the original servers would
have to get re-replaced to different
nodes in the cluster and that would be
very bad we want to keep everything in a
pretty consistent server
okay so first let's talk about key range
partitioning as you can see on the left
here all that really is is saying we're
going to take a bunch of keys
divide them into ranges and assign a
partition to each range
the ranges are not necessarily even
because obviously we don't want hot
spots and say there are certain you know
like letters or keys that there are a
lot more rows corresponding to that
range then we want to be able to split
that one into even smaller chunks
so generally within each partition we're
keeping the keys sorted to best support
range queries so looking at the pros and
cons of this approach the biggest pro is
that it's very simple and it allows for
effective range queries the biggest con
is that it easily leads to hot spots as
a result of you know it's kind of hard
to just look at a range of keys and say
like we know exactly the query patterns
and balances that are going to happen in
each range
the bigger thing is that even though
some databases dynamically do this we'll
see
in a few slides that that can be a
little bit problematic too
okay let's look at hash range
partitioning so all we're doing here is
taking a hash of the key and putting it
into the proper partition so below
you'll see i have three databases the
first one has all keys with a hash up to
f22 476
the second database has
all of the hashes from f22 476 to r91
mbb and then the last database has
everything else so let's say i want to
take the key jordan hash that and put it
into a proper database
i'm going to pass it through a hash
function get the result of that and as
you can see that means it's going to go
into database 2 because that's the range
that it belongs it
in terms of the pros and cons of hash
range partitioning the biggest pro is
that now keys are going to be evenly
distributed between nodes that means
that you're assuming there's going to be
a good hash function though which is
it's pretty easy to use if you just use
like sha or something like that
the biggest con is that you can't do
range queries anymore if two keys that
are next to each other alphabetically
are both hashing to very different
values there's no guarantee that they're
going to be on the same partition and as
a result a range query might touch every
single partition which would be very
inefficient
furthermore if a key has a lot of
activity there's still going to be
hotspots so even though the keys might
be evenly distributed if i'm constantly
updating or writing to a given key then
it is going to be problematic
one strategy that you can actually use
to kind of mitigate this a little bit is
you take the key that is very popular
you add a random number to it let's say
between like one and twenty and then you
hash the key plus that random number so
that um you know one twentieth of the
load
on the key is actually going to be
distributed the disadvantage of that is
that every time you make a query you
have to search all 20 of those
you know like key plus random number
values and aggregate that data
okay indexes in a partition database
configuration so in the first video on
this channel i've spoken about indexes
and if you recall and index is literally
just basically saying um here's some
metadata where we have a value for a
field or a column and then all of the
primary keys that correspond to it so a
secondary index is the same thing so
let's imagine i have a database of
basketball players and i have a
secondary index on the position column
and so as you can see for each position
i have a list of all the primary keys
corresponding to that position
okay so let's talk about two secondary
index options and partition data sets
because they both have trade-offs to
them so there's local indexes and
there's global indexes
the first is local indexes so the whole
point is to hold a secondary index that
only encapsulates the data on that
specific partition so you'll see here if
you look at the two tables i have two
different partitions each of them is
holding three basketball players and i
have a secondary index on position again
so you can see that the secondary index
corresponding to the first partition or
the top one only encapsulates that data
it only has michael jordan lebron james
and kobe bryant in it additionally for
the second partition it only has chris
middleton chris paul and dwight howard
in that secondary index so what are the
trade-offs of the local index well for
starters it's really fast for writing
because it means that writes are all
being kept within the partition the
secondary index is only looking at
values that are actually stored on that
partition and don't actually have to
look at the values stored on other
partitions
the issue though is that local indexes
are very slow on read why is that
because if we want to actually use our
secondary index to perform a fast read
query we have to go and check every
single partition and aggregate the
results of their local secondary index
okay now let's talk about the other
option which is global indexes the idea
here is that we're actually partitioning
the secondary index itself amongst the
partitions in a perhaps different or
random way than the actual partitions
are split up so as you can see on the
first partition we're actually only
holding the point guard and center
parts of the secondary index so even
though chris paul and dwight howard
aren't on the top partition they're
being held in the secondary index for it
similarly if you look at the secondary
partition we see that the power forward
small forward and shooting guard parts
of the secondary index are held there
and even as a result of that lebron
james who is on the top partition is
still being kept track of in that
secondary index and so are kobe bryant
and michael jordan
so what are the advantages and cons of
the global index well they're really
fast on read because now say i want to
find all small forwards i can literally
just go and actually check that
secondary index and it'll get me the row
ids of everything
the biggest con is that they're very
slow on right because now every single
write has to go to multiple partitions
another even further potentially bigger
issue is the fact that let's say one of
my rights succeeds the right to the
partition succeeds but then the right to
the secondary index fails we might need
some sort of consensus mechanism or
transaction that allows either both of
them to succeed or both of them to fail
finally let's talk about rebalancing
partitions so i've mentioned so far how
we might split data and how we might
keep up indexes for data but eventually
you're going to be adding more nodes to
the system and you're going to want to
be able to rebalance your data so that
it best suits all of the nodes in your
pool
okay the whole point of this though is
that when rebalancing partitions we want
to remap the minimum amount of keys
possible such that we're avoiding
hotspots you don't want to remap
everything because that would put a ton
of congestion on the network
okay so let's imagine that we start with
one approach which is a fixed number of
partitions so even though let's say i
have four nodes in my cluster i'm
actually going to have a number of
partitions that's much greater than that
where each node holds a few partitions
at a time so let's say right now that
each node is holding four partitions so
as you can see we have these four
rectangles and within each rectangle
sorry each node is holding five
partitions
and those are delineated by the
different color so we have 20 partitions
in total now let's say i'm going to
actually add a fifth node
once i do this i'm going to take the
white chunk from each of those existing
partitions and put those together to
fill up the fifth note
during the time that these partitions
are being copied over to the new node
the old node is still accepting reads
and writes for them and then the second
that copy is done the new partition is
actually taking them on
a similar thing would happen if we were
to remove it remove a node so if we went
from four to three nodes the node being
removed would go ahead and donate some
of its partitions to those existing
nodes
okay so what are things to consider when
you have a fixed number of partitions
well the hardest thing really is that
you have to choose a fixed number that
is reasonable
if it's too small and there aren't
enough partitions what's going to end up
happening is that each partition is
going to get too big and our app won't
scale
because then we have these huge
partitions that no longer even fit on a
single database node anymore and that's
going to be a huge problem additionally
partitions that are too big are going to
take a really long time to transfer over
the network to another node if we were
to add one to our pool
if it's too high then there's going to
be overhead on disk for each partition
that we store just by virtue of saying
like hey here is the range of things in
here and additionally there's going to
be overhead in keeping track of where
each partition is located and as a
result of that having too many
partitions is also going to slow down
your system
the one thing to note here is that say
you are just starting out from a really
small app but you know your app is going
to grow a ton in the future
but your app is going to grow a ton in
the future maybe a fixed number of
partitions isn't the best solution
simply by virtue of the fact that it's
going to be really hard to predict one
number
okay so let's talk about dynamic
partitioning which tries to kind of fix
this
so certain databases will actually go
ahead and create extra partitions for
you once a given partition exceeds a
certain size i think in some it's like
10 gigabytes or something like that
so
or even if the partition becomes too
small it'll actually merge it with other
smaller partitions
so
the reason that not everyone uses this
is because let's say we leave dynamic
partitioning completely up to the
database
if the database assumes that a node is
down it might try to rebalance
automatically and give some of its
partitions to another node and if this
is because of a network issue then we
end up over congesting the network
okay now let's look at a third approach
which is a fixed number of partitions
per node
so as the data set grows each of the
partitions on each node is going to grow
proportionally with it
however if a new node joins the cluster
what these algorithms will actually do
is take some pieces of the partitions on
each node and they'll typically you know
take like a little chunk from each or
something and then go ahead and take
those for themselves if you've heard of
the algorithm consistent hashing which
i'll eventually make a video about this
is actually pretty similar to that it's
basically like taking a bunch of random
points around a ring and making it so
that that new
node is going to handle these parts of
the partition
okay to summarize sharding
unlike replication which is kind of
necessary for ensuring data durability
and availability partitioning is
something that adds a lot of complexity
and it's not something that you always
actually want to do in your application
unless you're really forced to it
happens to be the case that most
applications when they're at scale do
actually need to deal with sharding
because
you know a single machine can't handle
the throughput and the amount of data
that it needs to
also generally keep in mind that there
tends to be some sort of either routing
tier or coordination service as you can
see in the image below that keeps track
of which partition
is on which node and the corresponding
ip address another way that some
services deal with this is using a
gossip protocol which is basically where
the database nodes actually communicate
amongst themselves without a third party
service like zookeeper
however the point is that partitioning
does actually require a lot of tracking
to keep track of where everything is and
occasionally rebalance so it does add a
lot of complexity
to continue and discuss you know one
more time the trade-offs that we made
throughout this video in terms of
partitioning methodology key ranges are
really good for performing range queries
however they can easily lead to hot
spots if you don't choose good ones
similarly key hash ranges are really
good when you want to evenly distribute
the data but there's no guarantee that
there won't be hot spots as well because
of the fact that certain keys might have
a lot of load on them
as far as index choices local indexes
optimize for write speed because you
don't have to communicate across
partitions
whereas global indexes optimize for read
speed in the sense that they're slower
on right because you potentially have to
make two writes to two different nodes
however
when you're actually reading then it's
simply one read from one node and you
get all the data that you want
finally in terms of rebalancing choices
it's pretty simple to use a fixed number
of partitions but it's not simple to
actually choose that fixed number
similarly a changing number of
partitions may scale better but you know
leaving all of this dynamically to a
database might lead to rebalancing when
you don't have to and add some strain on
your system
overall yeah that's kind of sharding
summarized as fast as i can but i think
i covered most of the important points
feel free to let me know if there's
anything else i need to cover and yeah
feel free to comment other stuff you
want me to talk about it's uh it's been
useful so far to hear from actual
viewers